this one's definitely been about six
years in the making with the initial
germ of the idea the wisp of the idea I
like that way pitched way back in 2004
by Brenda Chapman one of our directors
and development and as a filmmaker
driven studio all the ideas come from
right there in the studio and so Brenda
pitched the earliest idea about that was
inspired by her relationship with her
own daughter she had a six-year-old
daughter who was very feisty and
opinionated already at six and Brenda
thought what kind of teenager will this
make and out of that relationship she
began to weave the tail and and pitch
that initial idea to John Lasseter and
our creative brain trust and so that was
the okay yes let's develop this into a
film but you know in terms of putting a
crew together and all that that didn't
happen until more like 2006 to become
the movie that you see today Brenda
Chapman being of Scottish heritage mark
andrews our director also being of
Scottish heritage as it turns out and
having this having great love for the
country it was this perfect landscape
steeped in story and myth and legend for
this this folk tale idea so some of the
first research books were my books that
I brought in on Scotland and on Scottish
legends and stuff like that to give to
Brenda and the crew to start just
picking through and you know looking at
it and you know whatever they can pull
from the legends and myths that might
make you know give them more information
to help build the story the stuff about
the the clan symbols you know that's
ancient Scottish legends that go way
back to Celtic mythos will the wisps you
know those kind of things this thing
that is animation film making is never
in context you know we don't go out on
in the sets or out on locations with the
actors and the lights and everything in
go okay here's your pages now we set the
camera up here and come down now go and
you see the scene unfold we don't see
the scene unfold we have to make create
the scene to unfold and then get it in a
format where we could see it unfold then
to start making those decisions that you
make on the set or in live action you
know on location instantaneously you
know so the actor may come down
okay now that I'm seeing it let's change
it and do this you know coming a little
bit more aggressive and you know let's
see what happens you know you get that
spontaneity happening so we have to
constantly build up to a state of
context because we're working with so
many different little pieces I mean we
start with a script we're basically
rewriting right constantly okay and we
put the film up on reels in the
storyboard form three or four times a
year right yeah and basically rewriting
every cycle and redrawing and-and-and on
this film we did it a huge amount i mean
i think we had 130 scenes in story and
there's 36 scenes in the movie so we
went through a lot of stuff for this
move well in live-action you have a day
of two months shoot or whatever and the
footage you get is the footage you're
stuck with and in animation you can do
anything and it's ended you can we
always say the good news is you do
anything the bad news is you do anything
it's because it's it's it's kind of
endless and it's but it's it's a also an
amazing process our goal for the sets
and environments is to feel like we were
really in Scotland and not filming it
down in San Jose or you know Boston or
something we really tried to pull the
nuggets of Scotland we did a lot of
research and the clothing that was set
back in the 10th 11th century so we
really try to do our research and know
our stuff so it's believable then once
we do that we can kind of shoot off and
caricature things a bit you'll start
seeing things that are more designed in
the film and less realistic we don't
ever want to hit you over the head with
it and sort of start putting Celtic
knots and the clouds or things but there
there there subtly sort of exposed in
the visuals at the film early on brave I
was doing some lighting tests on the
forest and as the computers want to do
it sort of barked on me a little bit and
it dropped all the lights out of the
scene
but left the mist there which is a very
important part of setting a movie in
Scotland as you know there's all this
mist and in the forest the mist is this
beautiful thing so suddenly I had no
light but missed and I got all of these
incredible silhouettes of all these
Scottish plants and all of this depth
without kind of overwhelming busyness
and it became this thing that I fell in
love with sort of and so we were going
for a sort of a theatrical lighting
setup with the the light orchestrated in
the forest where the action was
happening but then I let the flight fall
off into the forest so it would actually
go black which served the story in two
different ways which is we have this
forest for all this mysticism happens
and all of these you know our twists and
turns happen there and so letting things
go off into darkness leaves it much more
mysterious you have no idea what's going
to happen and it's also this really
great metaphor for a teenage girl you
know in the castle she's comfortable
she's around her parents and her family
but you know as a teenager you're sort
of got one step into the next world
which is a much more uncomfortable place
where you don't know what's going on and
so when she's in the forest and you sort
of never know what's out there and it's
sort of supporting that that one foot in
both worlds kind of thing